hi there steve kaufman here
um today i'm going to talk about
listening i'm going to talk about what i
consider to be the three stages
of sort of a listening strategy
um i'm
experimenting today i'm in a different
room this room has a
carpet on the floor has some curtains
hanging here
and so i think the sound will be better
i may get some of those uh movers
blankets you know to hang on the wall in
order to absorb more sound if that turns
out to be worthwhile
you've got these goofy
fish prints behind me um i might even
spring for some kind of a backdrop but i
don't know if i need to go that far
i might get another light on the side
here to get you know more even lighting
at any rate i'm learning i'm learning
about it because
you know everyone i think we all like to
improve i mean language learning is all
about improving improving usually means
learning more about something and as we
learn more about something then we can
you know develop
better skills and so i'm trying to do a
better job with my podcast
but getting back to the subject of
listening
so i thought about it today i went for a
run yesterday
without listening to any language
and of course that's a good time to
think you know you need some time to
think i can't spend all my time
listening to language
uh and and it dawned on me that there
are three stages in our listening
strategy
there's an initial stage
uh where we need a lot of repetition so
i would call this sort of intensive
listening this is where i listened 30 or
40 times to the same many stories
not right away but i'll go lesson one
two three four five back to lesson one
two three four five eventually six seven
eight nine ten back to one and so you're
listening repeatedly to a lot of the
same content
a lot of this content as in the case of
our many stories has a lot of high
frequency verbs
you're certainly going to come across
the high frequency words and verbs often
and therefore it's easier to get to know
them
and as you listen to this stuff whereas
when you started everything was just
noise and you think you'll never learn
this language and particularly if it's
written a difficult or a different
script like the arabic script
but with time
all of a sudden you know you start to
understand things
and then you and this is what i've often
referred to as the sort of steep part of
the upside down hockey stick
all of a sudden you understand something
you can say something you feel good
about yourself now comes the second
part of the sort of listening strategy
and this is where
you need to you suddenly realize that
the the sort of high frequency verbs the
frequency drops off off so quickly
that the words that you need to know
they they appear so infrequently now
that they're much more difficult to
learn
and
but so in that second period if i go to
the third period you know i was thinking
about it today the third period the
final period is where i came to in
russian or in czech
or some of the other languages that i
have learned
are portuguese
i'm not there yet in korean i'm
certainly not there i'm there in czech
and ukrainian
these are the languages i'm not there in
greek or romanian
these are the languages where i can just
grab anything
and i will understand most of it
and so i don't have to listen more than
once if i have access to the transcript
i read it i might pick up a few words
but but by and large
i can go for a run like i went for a run
yesterday and i can be listening to
something that's interesting on whatever
is of interest to me history literature
politics and i'm
reviewing
words and phrases that i've you know
learned
i'm learning new things my brain is
getting used to the language i'm kind of
launched there it's a little difficult
but it's not very difficult and it's
very satisfying that's the sort of goal
uh and and once you're in that
third stage where you can listen for
enjoyment and listen out of interest and
you're you're just filling your brain
with phrases and words in the language
words that you've learned once twice
three times they come up again you're
just strengthening your hold on the
language that's a very solid base from
which to really embark in speaking and
speaking speaking often and speaking of
on subjects of interest which i can do
with the tutor online or if i go to the
country i'm now launched in the language
so how do we get there
so the first stage was kind of
getting a toehold in the language with a
lot of repetitive listening
and that third stage is when the
difficult interesting authentic material
is is accessible comprehensible and you
can just go off listening to it put it
in your car listen to it you're just
enjoying the language you're enjoying
the rewards of your labor
how do we get there and i often get this
question or how how do we jump from
essentially
a2
to b2
uh in the european framework
and there it's just uh we have to make
that investment
we have to invest in acquiring more
words
so that eventually we can then listen
and enjoy it
so what i do uh now at link is i go into
sentence mode
and i use the five second repeat
and i just try to especially in farsi
where we don't have text to speech and i
listen to it and i listen to the
sentence and i listen to the sentence
again and i look up the new words and i
hear the sentence again and i kind of
proceed but i'm dealing with authentic
interesting potentially interesting
content difficult content
and
gradually and ever so gradually i'm not
getting worse you know this is the thing
uh the brain likes to learn we all like
to learn
there are no shortcuts but every little
you know every time i put effort into it
even though i think i'm not getting in
anywhere of course i am i'm building up
my vocabulary my ability to to
understand what i hear not just when i
read and that's difficult because you
can read through it and pick out the
words and
you didn't quite get it the first time
but you look at the word you know what
it is and then you hear it and it's
still not comprehensible and you just
have to continue so in a way
the the rewards are fewer in that middle
stage
uh you're not listening as often to the
same material because typically whereas
the the mini stories are four minutes
long here you i might be dealing with a
podcast that's 15 minutes long and i'm
going through it through it sentence by
sentence and i'm working it and mining
it for words and phrases and save a word
and then i save the phrase and if it's
in arabic i can hear the text of speech
of the phrase or i use the
actual live audio track
go over that
sentence by the way i shouldn't
spill the beans so to speak but
we're working on a number of interesting
things for link and one of which one of
these will be the ability in sentence
view to set the timestamps because the
automatic timestamps often don't work
and so
you know you you click on the
text-to-speech for that sentence you get
the text-to-speech we want it to be so
that you click on that
uh you know audio indicator and you get
the natural voice for that sentence so
all of these things are going to become
better there's a number of things that
we have on the pipeline that are going
to make it better
and i think a big part of it is to make
that that intermediate stage where we're
building ourselves up so that we will be
able to and that's the goal we will be
able to eventually just grab an
interesting audiobook an interesting
podcast
just listen to it enjoy it discover the
culture discover the language
feed the brain and all this kind of
stuff and that's kind of the third
that's the glide portion okay so just to
summarize so i see three stages there's
the initial very steep climb but you
have that sense that you've you're
achieving something
then you have that long grind where you
just have to sock in more words and
phrases train the brain
sentence mode or
full lesson mode whatever you prefer
so that you eventually get to the point
where now you can just listen for fun
and now you're well on your way and when
you're good at listening for when you do
a lot of listening for fun and you have
a significant vocabulary then you can
really start speaking a lot which you
eventually have to do you have to speak
a lot in order to speak well and and i
would say that in my own strategy
learning strategy you know even now i'm
spending all my time working with these
texts
developing my ability to understand what
i hear increasing my vocabulary i'm not
doing any online tutor sessions it would
be fun to do it but i just feel i don't
have enough i'm more concerned about how
well i'm going to speak at the end of my
journey rather than what i'm able to do
you know
in the first phase or the second phase
although i enjoyed interacting with my
tutors and i may i may get started
especially in farsi where we don't have
text of speech just in order to have a
better sense of these words
[Music]
anyway there you have it three stages in
our
language learning strategy i hope that
was helpful for now